OF COURSE I WANT TO PUNCH HIM IN
THE FACE.
>> Tucker: ANGRY OLD GUY.
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST MARK STEYN
JOINS US TO MARVEL HOW RICH
PEOPLE HATE TRUMPETED THE MORE
PRIVILEGED YOU ARE, THE MATTER
YOU ARE ABOUT TRUMP.
>> THAT'S THE WAY TO LOOK AT IT.
ROBERT DE NIRO LIVES BETTER THAN
99.99% OF PEOPLE IN THE ENTIRETY
OF HUMAN HISTORY.
HAVE EVER LIVED.
HE CANNOT ACCEPT THAT A CLOSED
ELECTION IN A 50/50 COUNTRY
DIDN'T GO HIS WAY.
THIS IS DEEPLY BIZARRE.
YOU MENTION -- I HAVE NEVER
HEARD OF THESE AMERICAN ICON
AWARDS AND I THINK IT'S A STUPID
TITLE.
IN AUSTRALIA THEY HAVE AN AWARD
CALLED NATIONAL TREASURE WHICH
AGAIN DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE KIND
OF THING YOU GET NOMINATED FOR.
THESE KIND OF NAMES ARE IN THE
GIFT OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
GENERAL MOOD.
BUT IF YOU DO ACTUALLY HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED UN-AMERICAN NOT
GOD AWARD, THAN THE GUY HAS TO
BE AN ICON AWARD FOR ALL
AMERICANS, INCLUDING THE 60
WHATEVER MILLION PEOPLE WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP.
IT'S NOT JUST THE HOLLYWOOD
PARTISAN ICON AWARDS.
IF I WERE AL PACINO OR ANYBODY
ELSE AT RISK OF GETTING AN AWARD
SPEECH PRIZE PRESENTED TO ME BY
ROBERT DE NIRO, I WOULD START
COUNTING THE EQUIVALENT OF AN
ORGAN DONOR CARD SAYING IN THE
EVENT I GET NOMINATED FOR A
PRESTIGIOUS AWARD, I DON'T WANT
ROBERT DE NIRO GIVING THE SPEECH
ROBERT DE NIRO GIVING THE SPEEC.
HE TALKS ABOUT TRUMP FOR
7 MINUTES AND THEN SAYS BY THE
WAY, HERE'S A STATUE FOR
AL PACINO.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS BEYOND ARRANGEMENT.
HE HAS ACTUALLY BECOME MORE
INSANE THAN TRAVIS BICKEL IN
"TAXI DRIVER.
>> Tucker: USUALLY THE REV
REVOLUTIONARY SPIRIT IS AIMED
UPWARD.
YOU WATCH THIS PARADE OF THE
MOST PRIVILEGED PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY SHOUTING DOWN AT TRUMP'S
VOTERS, DAMN YOU, WORKING CLASS
AMERICANS.
YOU MUST BE QUIET.
HOW DARE YOU SPEAK?
HAS THERE EVER BEEN A REVOLUTION
AIMED DOWN?
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
PHENOMENON IN SOME WAYS.
THE ELITES RISING UP AGAINST THE
MASSES.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
>> I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY TRUE.
I SAW SOMETHING OF IT WITH MRS.
MRS. THATCHER IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM OR ESSENTIALLY
PRIVILEGED ELITE ARTISTIC PEOPLE
REGARDED HER AS VULGAR AND LOWER
CLASS IN THE SAME WHETHER THEY
DO DO WITH TRUMP.
THE FACT IS THEY ARE KILLING
THEMSELVES.
THERE IS A BOOK OUT THE MOMENT,
THE NOVELIST OF AMERICAN PSYCHO,
HE VOTED FOR HILLARY.
HE IS GAY.
HE'S NO CONSERVATIVE RIGHT WING.
HE WAS DATING A MILLENNIAL GUY
AND THE MILLENNIAL GUY WENT FULL
TRUMP ARRANGEMENT SYNDROME AND
BECAME IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE WITH
AND THAT'S THE SAME SITUATION.
WOULD YOU WANT TO WAKE UP IN BED
WITH ROBERT DE NIRO EVERY
MORNING BORING ON ABOUT TRUMP?
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE AMERICAN
ICON AWARDS.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEST CRANKY
EMBITTERED GRANDPA 40 YEARS
AFTER HIS ACTING BEST AWARD.
HE WOULD BE A SHOO-IN.
>> Tucker: HE WOULD DEFTLY BE
IN THE RUNNING.
I WOULD ARGUE THERE'S OTHER
CONTENDERS.
[LAUGHS]
>> IT'S A CROWDED FIELD AND IT'S
NOT EVEN AN AGE THING, AS WE SAW
WITH THE INSUFFERABLE MILLENNIAL